what's your favorite baseball movie of
all time the sandlock what's your
favorite sport to watch besides football
I like the Browns but I'm more of an
Eagles fan I think what is your favorite
accessory to wear a hat what's your
favorite City to play besides your own
ooh St Louis just a cool Park and it
could be a Tuesday Day game and it's
pretty packed who was your favorite
player to play against Howard po just
watching him growing up so that was
pretty cool to play against him where is
your favorite vacation spot Hawaii what
is your favorite shoe I like my Travis
Scouts what's your favorite clothing
brand Nike who is your favorite current
athlete I'm going to go with Jaylen Herz
what's your favorite candy to eat at the
theaters Cookie Dough Bites